SURROUNDING FREEDOM OF THE
PRESS.
IT'S TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
BREAKING NEWS OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
WE ARE EXCITED.
IT IS OFFICIAL.
WE ARE HITTING THE ROAD.
NEXT WEEK WE WILL BE ON THE
GROUND IN SINGAPORE.
OF COURSE TO COVER THE LATEST
FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
HISTORIC AND CONSEQUENTIAL
TALKS WITH THE DICTATOR KIM
JONG UN.
TONIGHT WE ARE DAYS AWAY FROM
THE DIRECT TALKS BETWEEN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA AND
NORTH KOREA.
SOMETHING MANY THOUGHT WAS
IMPOSSIBLE.
SOMETHING OBAMA, CLINTON AND
KERRY AND OTHERS AND THE
FRIENDS ON THE LEFT COULD ONLY
DREAM OF.
THIS COULD BE ONE OF THE
SIGNIFICANT SUMMITS OF MODERN
HISTORY.
>> President Trump: I HAVE
BEEN PREPARING ALL MY LIFE.
I BELIEVE IN PREPARATION.
I HAVE BEEN PREPARING ALL MY
LIFE.
THE ONE-WEEK PREPARATIONS
DON'T WORK.
JUST ASK HILLARY WHAT HAPPENED
TO HER IN THE DEBATE.
I HAVE BEEN PREPARING ALL MY
LIFE.
>> Sean: WE REMINDED
EVERYBODY REMEMBER THE DEBATES
WITH HILLARY?
AND THE SECRETARY OF STATE
MIKE POMPEO WHO HAS BEEN
WORKING VERY HARD ON ALL OF
THIS.
HE WEIGHED IN.
LOOK AT THAT.
>> THE FACT THAT THE TWO
LEADERS ARE COMING TO THE
TABLE SHOWS THAT THE TWO SIDES
ARE SERIOUS.
THE DIPLOMATIC MODEL USED
TODAY IS DIFFERENT FROM THE
PAST EFFORTS.
OUR EFFORTS GIVE US HOPE WE
CAN FIND REAL SUCCESS FOR PAST
EFFORTS HAVE FALLEN SHORT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS HOPEFUL.
HE IS ALSO GOING IN THE SUMMIT
WITH HIS EYES WIDE OPEN.
WE HAVE SEEN HOW MANY
INADEQUATE AGREEMENTS HAVE
BEEN STRUCK IN THE PAST.
YOU CAN BE SURE THAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP WILL NOT STAND FOR A BAD
DEAL.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
HOW DO WE GET TO THIS POINT?
HISTORY LESSON.
"HANNITY" HISTORY LESSON.
WE START IN THE '90s.
BILL CLINTON.
HEB HE MET WITH KIM JONG UN'S
FATHER, KIM JONG IL.
HE PROMISED THIS WAS A GOOD
DEAL FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND HE PAID BILLIONS IN ENERGY
SUBSIDIARIES AND MADE
CONCESSIONS AS IF THIS WOULD
MAKE FOR WORLD PEACE.
IT DIDN'T WORK OUT.
YOU MAY REMEMBER THIS.
>> THIS IS A GOOD DEAL FOR THE
UNITED STATES.
NORTH KOREA WILL FREEZE AND
THEN DISMANTLE THE NUCLEAR
PROGRAM.
SOUTH KOREA AND OUR OTHER
ALLIES WILL BE BETTER PROTECT
ED.
SOUTH KOREA WITH SUPPORT FROM
JAPAN AND OTHER NATIONS WILL
BEAR MOST OF THE COST TO
PROVIDE KOREA WITH FUEL TO
MAKE UP FOR THE NUCLEAR ENERGY
IT IS LOSING.
THEY WILL PAY FOR ALTERNATIVE
SYSTEM TO ALLOW THEM TO
PRODUCE ELECTRICITY TO MAKE IT
HARDER TO PRODUCE NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
THE UNITED STATES AND THE
INTERNATIONAL INSPECTORS WILL
CAREFULLY MONITOR NORTH KOREA.
TO MAKE SURE IT KEEPS ITS
COMMITMENTS.
ONLY AS IT DOES SO WILL THEY
FULLY JOIN THE COMMUNITY OF
NATIONS.
>> Sean: BILL CLINTON WAS
DEAD WRONG.
NORTH KOREA SUCCESSFULLY
DEVELOPED A NUCLEAR WEAPONS
PROGRAM.
UNDER EIGHT YEARS OF THE
FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA, HIS
WEAK AND FECKLESS LEADERSHIP,
WHILE KIM JONG UN'S ACTIONS
BECAME MORE HOSTILE.
PRESIDENT OBAMA LEFT TRUMP
WITH UNFETTERED INTERNATIONAL
DISASTER AFTER DISASTER.
THIS IS JUST ONE.
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP TOOK
OFFICE IN 2017, THE SITUATION
IN NORTH KOREA WAS AT A
BOILING POINT.
REMEMBER, KIM JONG UN SHOOTING
THE LONG-RANGE MISSILES OVER
JAPAN.
THREATENING TO BLOW UP GUAM.
AFTER EIGHT YEARS OF WEAK,
PATHETIC SPINELESS LEADERSHIP
UNDER OBAMA, THINGS HAVE
CHANGED.
PRESIDENT TRUMP RESPONDED.
YOU MAY REMEMBER THIS.
>> President Trump: NORTH
KOREA BEST NOT MAKE ANY MORE
THREATS TO THE UNITED STATES.
THEY WILL BE MET WITH FIRE,
FURY AND FRANKLY POWER.
THE LIKES ANY HAVE EVER SEEN
BEFORE.
PEOPLE QUESTIONING WAS IT TOO
TOUGH?
MAYBE IT WASN'T TOUGH ENOUGH.
THEY HAVE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
THE COUNTRY FOR A LONG TIME.
FOR MANY YEARS.
IT'S TIME THAT SOMEBODY STUCK
UP FOR THE PEOPLE OF THIS
COUNTRY AND FOR THE PEOPLE OF
THE OTHER COUNTRIES.
IT'S A TRAGEDY AND IT CAN'T BE
ALLOWED.
IF ANYTHING HAPPENS TO GUAM,
THERE WILL BE BIG TROUBLE IN
NORTH KOREA.
IF HE DOES ANYTHING WITH
RESPECT TO GUAM OR ANYPLACE
ELSE THAT IS AN EMERGENCY
TERRITORY OR AN AMERICAN ALLY
HE WILL TRULY REGRET IT.
HE WILL REGRET IT FAST.
ROCKET MAN ON A SUICIDE
MISSION FOR HIMSELF.
AND FOR REGIME.
>> Sean: OF COURSE THE
PRESIDENT THEN BACKED UP HIS
TOUGH RHETORIC WITH ACTION.
AND HE SENT MULTIPLE CARRIER
AND STRIKE GROUPS TO THE
REGION.
HE RAMPED UP DEVASTATING
SANCTIONS AGAINST NORTH KOREA.
AND, OF COURSE, PUT A LOT OF
PRESSURE ON NORTH KOREA'S
BIGGEST ALLY, CHINA.
HE FORGED A GREAT RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE CHINESE PRESIDENT.
WHAT THIS IS CALLED, THESE
WORDS ARE PEACE THROUGH
STRENGTH.
BY THE WAY, IT SAID YOUR MAIN
STREAM CORRUPT DESTROY TRUMP
MEDIA TO A HYSTERICAL FIT.
YOU CAN'T MAKE IT UP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE IDEA OF A NUCLEAR
SHOWDOWN WITH NORTH KOREA
KEEPS YOU AT NIGHT?
I WOULD RECOMMEND DELETING
YOUR TWITTER APP.
>> HE'S NOT BEING CAVALIER
WITH A THREAT OF NUCLEAR WAR,
IT'S CAVALIER IN A WAY THAT
MAKES HIM SEENDY MEANTED.
>> THIS IS FROM A PERSON WHO
IS NOT WELL, FROM A LEADER NOT
FIT FOR OFFICE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GOODING
KIM JONG
GOODING -- GOADING KIM JONG UN
TO TEST THE NUCLEAR FACILITY
AND SHOW HIM WRONG.
FUNDAMENTALLY IT COMES ACROSS
AS TWO KINDERGARTENERS
JOSTLING EACH OTHER BUT THEY
EACH HAVE NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
>> TOO LATE AFTER 100 MILLION
AMERICANS DIE.
>> THAT IS WHERE WE ARE.
THIS IS NOT AN EXAGGERATION.
>> TRUMP'S COMMENT ABOUT THE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS HAVE THE
EXPERTS WORRIED HE COULD
TRIGGER A CATASTROPHE.
>> Sean: WE KNOW FOR CERTAIN
THAT THE MEDIA IS ABSOLUTELY
WRONG.
THEY WERE WRONG.
THEY ARE WRONG.
ALL ICBM TESTS DONE.
THEY RETURN THREE AMERICAN
HOSTAGES.
THEY AGREE TO DISCUSS THE
COMPLETE DENUCLEARIZATION OF
THE KOREAN PENINSULA IN
EXCHANGE FOR NO CONCESSIONS.
HE CROSSED OVER THE D.M.Z. TO
THE ARMS OF THE SOUTH KOREAN
PRESIDENT AND DISMANTLED ONE
OF THE NUCLEAR TEST SITES.
DESPITE THE DIPLOMATIC
PROGRESS YOUR MEDIA IS HATING
AND DOUBTING AND SADLY MANY
EVEN ACTIVELY ROOTING FOR
FAILURE.
THIS WOULD BE GREAT FOR THE
WORLD.
OUR KIDS, OUR GRAND KIDS.
LOOK AT THE NBC CONSPIRACY
HOST QUESTIONING TRUMP'S
PREPAREDNESS FOR THE UPCOMING
SUMMIT.
WATCH THIS.
>> WE HAVE TO POINT OUT, THE
PRESIDENT WAS CRITICAL WHEN WE
PLAYED THAT CLIP OF HIM
TALKING OF BEING PREPARED FOR
THE NORTH KOREA SUMMIT WE
DIDN'T ADD WHAT HE SAID AT THE
END.
HE WAS CRITICAL.
HE SAID, "I'VE BEEN PREPARING
ALL MY LIFE."
I'D LOVE TO KNOW WHEN WAS
THAT?
WHEN YOU APPEARED IN A PLAYBOY
SOFT CORN MURPH VIE OR BODY
SLAMMED VINCE McMAHON OR
WHEN YOU WERE LEAKING
INFORMATION WHEN YOU DISGUISED
YOURSELF AZURE OWN P.R. GUY
TALKING TO TABLOIDS ABOUT WHAT
A GREAT LOVER YOU WERE.
>> Sean: TAKE A LOOK AT THE
COVER FROM "THE ECONOMIST"
SHOWING PRESIDENT IN PLACE OF
MILEY CYRUS, THE WRECKING BALL
THAT WAS INFAMOUS.
SAYING EVEN IF HE STRIKES A
DEAL WITH NORTH KOREA THE
FOREIGN POLICY WILL HARM THE
WORLD.
THAT IS ROOTING FOR FAILURE.
THE MEDIA TRIES TO BASH THE
PRESIDENT AT EVERY TURN THEY
CAN'T HELP THEMSELVES.
HE HAS A LOT OF REALLY
IMPORTANT DIPLOMACY TO TACKLE.
WE'LL HAVE MORE ON THE
UPCOMING TALKS ON SINGAPORE
THROUGHOUT THE SHOW.
WE'LL BROADCAST THERE NEXT
WEEK.
FIRST TODAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP
LANDED IN QUEBEC IN CANADA TO
MEET WORLD LEADERS AT THE
ANNUAL G7 SUMMIT.
TENSIONS WERE RUNNING HIGH
AHEAD OF THE MEETING AFTER
PRESIDENT TRUMP ANNOUNCED
PLANS TO TACKLE SOME OF THE
UNFAIR TRADING INTERNATIONAL
PRACTICES WITH RETALIATORY
TARIFFS.
HE WANTS FREE AND FAIR TRADE.
HE WROTE PRIME MINISTER
TRUDEAU IS BEING INDIGNANT
BRINGING UP THE RELATIONSHIP
THAT THE U.S. AND CANADA HAD
OVER THE MANY YEARS AND OTHER
THINGS.
HE DOESN'T BRING UP THE FACT
THEY CHARGE UP TO 300% ON
DAIRY.
HURTING OUR FARMERS, KILLING
OUR AGRICULTURE.
HE CALLED IT'SLATED AND THIS
IS WHAT TRUMP SAID ABOUT WHAT
COULD BE A TENSE AND THE
INTERESTING G7 TRUMP SUMMIT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Trump: IF WE
ARE UNABLE TO MAKE A DEAL, WE
WILL TERMINATE NAFTA AND HAVE
A BETTER DEAL.
IF WE ARE UNABLE TO MAKE A
DEAL, WE WILL BE BETTER OFF.
THE E.U. TREATS US UNFAIRLY.
CANADA, UNFAIRLY, MEXICO,
UNFAIRLY.
WITH THAT SAID I THINK WE WILL
PROBABLY EASILY MAKE A DEAL.
>> Sean: WHILE THE PRESIDENT
IS BUSY DOING WHAT HE DOES
BEST, THAT IS NEGOTIATING, I
KNOW IF I ASK HIM TO COME ON
THE SHOW, I'LL GIVE YOU FIVE.
15.
HOW ABOUT SIX?
GIVE YOU 14.
THAT IS WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
DOES.
THE MEDIA HAS BEEN BEING DOING
WHAT THEY DO BEST.
SPREADING ANTI-TRUMP IT HAVE
HAVE -- VITRIOL.
ESPECIALLY AT NBC NEWS.
LOOK AT HOW DISGUSTING THE
CLIP IS NBC HOSTS ARE TRASHING
THE WOMEN IN THE PRESIDENT'S
LIFE.
THIS IS SO DERANGED AND OFF
THE RAILS.
YOU CAN'T MAKE IT UP.
>> YOU KNOW MORE ABOUT THE
TRUMP WOMEN, THE TRUMP FAMILY
THAN ANYONE.
WHAT DO THEY DO ON A DAY LIKE
TODAY?
ARE THEY THE MOST STOIC HUMAN
BEINGS?
ARE THEY NUMB, DEAD INSIDE,
PAID OFF?
WHAT IS THE DEAL?
>> YES, YES, AND YES.
I THINK THEY DO NOT SEE
PRESIDENT TRUMP THE WAY THAT
ALL OF US SEE PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEY HAVE A DISTORTED IMAGE OF
WHO HE IS.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE REACTION
WE DO.
>> THEIR MOTHERS KNOW.
THEY SEEM TO BE RAISING NICE
KIDS.
HOW DO THEY WALL IT OFF?
>> DEAD INSIDE?
ARE YOU PROUD OF THIS?
THIS IS YOUR NETWORK.
IS THAT NEWS TO YOU?
WHAT ABOUT THE CLIP BY THE WAY
FROM YOUR MORNING ANCHOR?
LIBERAL JOE.
AND ANDY LOOK, ARE YOU REALLY
PROUD OF THIS BIZARRE
CONSPIRACY THAT SHE IS NOW,
WELL, PAWNING OFF AS NEWS ON
YOUR SO-CALLED NEWS NETWORK?
HERE YOU GO.
I HOPE YOU LOVE IT.
>> THE HYPOCRISY IS ASTOUNDING
BECAUSE I KNOW SOMEONE WHO
SPOKE TO DONALD TRUMP RECENTLY
ABOUT LIFE IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
AND DONALD TRUMP'S BIGGEST
COMPLAINT IS HE IS NOT ALLOWED
TO WATCH PORN IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
SO THERE YOU GO.
THERE IS A LITTLE BIT OF NEWS
FOR YOU.
HE IS UPSET HE CAN'T WATCH
PORN IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> I BET THEY HAVE THOSE
ONE-900-NUMBERS BLOCKED, TOO,
WHICH MUST BE A
DISAPPOINTMENT.
>> I'M NOT SURE BUT IT FLIES
IN FACE OF ALL OF THIS.
>> Sean: OF COURSE, NBC NEWS
IS FAR FROM BEING THE ONLY
NEWS OUTLET WITH THE EXTREME
BIAS AGAINST THE PRESIDENT.
MANY IN THE MEDIA, WELL, THEY
HAVE BEEN GOING AFTER YOURS
TRULY ALL WEEK BECAUSE OF A
MONOLOGUE I DID EARLIER IN THE
WEEK.
ALL I DID WAS HIGHLIGHT A SAD
EXAMPLE OF WHAT IS A
TWO-TIERED JUSTICE SYSTEM IN
THIS COUNTRY.
WE DON'T HAVE EQUAL JUSTICE
UNDER THE LAW.
WE HAVE A SYSTEM OF JUSTICE
FOR THE CLINTONS AND ONE FOR
THE REST OF US.
I WAS OBVIOUSLY BEING
SARCASTIC AND MAKING A
COMPARISON.
I SAID WHAT IF I SAID THAT
THOSE THAT ROBERT MUELLER
REQUESTED THE PHONES FROM,
WHAT IF -- I SAID IT'S A BAD
IDEA.
KIDDING.
I SAID ALL SORT OF CAVEATS.
WHAT IF THEY FOLLOW HILLARY
CLINTON'S LEAD?
WHAT IF IN FACT THEY DECIDED
TO DELETE THE E-MAILS, WIPE
AWAY ALL EVIDENCE, ACID WASH
AND BLEACH THE HARD DRIVES ON
THE PHONES AND SMASH THEM UP
TO ITSY BITSY PIECES WITH
HAMMERS.
THEY WERE MORE MAD OF THE ME
THAN THEY WERE AT HILLARY FOR
ACTUALLY DOING THESE THINGS.
THIS IS A TASTE OF HOW THEY
DISTORTED THESE COMMENTS.
>> SEAN HANNITY IS NOW
LITERALLY TELLING POTENTIAL
WITNESSES AND SUBJECTS IN THE
MUELLER PROBE TO DESTROY THE
EVIDENCE.
AND HAMMER THE PHONES TO
PIECES.
>> HANNITY DEFENDERS MAY CALL
THAT SARCASM AND POETIC
LICENSE BUT WORDS ARE WORDS.
SEAN HANNITY LIVES OFF HIS
WORDS AND WE KNOW THEY HAVE A
HUGE IMPACT.
IF ANYONE DOES WHAT HE SAYS
THERE, THEY WOULD BE
COMMITTING A CRIME.
>> WHAT SEAN HANNITY ADMITTED
TO AND WAS ENTICING PEOPLE TO
DO AND ASKING THEM TO DO IS
DESTROY EVIDENCE, WHICH IS A
VIOLATION OF THE WITNESS
TAMPERING STATUTE.
>> NO RESPONSIBILITY PERSON ON
TELEVISION, NO RESPONSIBLE
SO-CALLED JOURNALIST SHOULD BE
ADVOCATING FOR PEOPLE TO
DESTROY EVIDENCE IN A SERIOUS
FEDERAL INVESTIGATION.
>> I DON'T THINK WE WILL SEE
HIM PROSECUTED.
FEDERAL PROSECUTORS GIVE
PEOPLE A WIDE BERTH ON
FIRST-AMENDMENT RELATED
CONDUCT SO UNLESS THERE IS
SOMETHING MORE SPECIFIC TO
LINK IT UP THIS IS WHAT WE
CATEGORIZE AS AWFUL BUT LAWFUL
CONDUCT.
>> LISTEN, IF HE IS ADVOCATING
FOR MUELLER'S WITNESSES TO
OBSTRUCT JUSTICE MAYBE MUELLER
SHOULD SPEAK TO HIM AND ASK
WHERE THE IDEA HAS COME FROM?
SAY THIS?
>> KNOWING MUELLER HE IS NOT
GOING TO LIGHT THAT FIRE UNDER
SOMEONE WHO GETS FREE AIR TIME
EVERY DAY.
HE CAN GO TO A JUDGE AND SAY
CEASE AND DESIST WHAT YOU'RE
DOING ON NATIONAL TELEVISION.
AND DID TRUMP GET THIS IDEA
FROM YOU?
>> Sean: CEASE AND DESIST?